hey you guys
flickers of fear time have kind of an
interesting
uh movie kind of an interesting story
behind how i ended up watching this one
and reviewing it
because if you guys know like if you've
seen any of our other
movie reviews any of the movie reviews
i've done any movie reviews that i've
done with tom
and i think i've mentioned on several
occasions that
of all the horror subgenres i'm not
a massive fan of found footage type of
movies and that's not to say
that you know there's not some found
footage movies that i haven't really
enjoyed and
mockumentaries i tend to like
mockumentaries more than found footage
but there have been some found footage
ones that i've liked
although it's generally not it's not a
sub genre that i
am like all that excited about so like
when a movie comes out that's kind of
like it's found footage i'm always kind
of like meh
i'll get to it eventually maybe like if
a bunch of people have told me that it's
good
so i kind of came at this film this is
the movie
unfriended this came out in 2014.
now this is essentially i guess you
could call it a found footage movie it
was actually made
entirely on a macbook uh laptop screen
so the whole entire all of the action uh
takes place
on a computer screen which as i said i
don't even think that was the first time
because i think there was a movie that
came out
uh called open windows wasn't toby
mcguire in that i want to say that was
kind of like a stalker
that was very much like had the same
sort of thing and it might have come out
the same year
but this one kind of got a lot of play
just because
of the gimmick and it you know and i
hate to
use that word because yes it's a gimmick
that the entire movie is made
on a laptop in real time like during a
skype conversation
but it's just really interesting that
this movie i probably wouldn't have
watched it because i just feel like oh
boy a bunch of like teens like talking
to each other like over skype for
80 minutes or whatever it is and it's
like found footage and they're all going
to like screech at each other and stuff
which they do but i don't know so this
movie is on netflix
and i was kind of like i really hadn't
much interest in watching it until i
kept seeing it pop up
like in a bunch of people's hey this
movie was like kind of forgotten about
her hey this movie is like way better
than most people probably think it is
just given the premise
i also heard i haven't seen the trailer
for it but i heard the trailer was like
terrible because i was reading like an
article
about it like you know shortly after it
came out and the person reviewing it was
kind of like oh wow i wasn't expecting
like i saw the trailer and i thought
this was gonna suck out loud but it's
like this is actually like way better
than it had any right to be
and it's actually quite a good movie so
i feel like the trailer maybe did it a
little bit of a disservice even though
like i said i haven't seen it
but this is just one of those ones that
kept turning up on people's lists it's
like on these horror channels there's
like oh you know i thought i was gonna
hate this movie but then i watched it
it's actually really really good and
really creepy and really effective
and so i decided that you know why not
i'll just uh
sit down and watch it and hopefully like
i said it's teens and it's all taking
place on a computer screen so hopefully
it won't piss me off too much
and i have to agree with like most
people this was actually
it's not like a masterpiece but this
movie is like really
effective and it was like way way better
than i was
expecting it to be now i will say that
in 2018
a sequel to this came out which was
called unfriended dark web
i haven't seen that one but i've heard
that one is like really really not as
good
um because i think what they did with
the sequel was that i mean
and this will probably have like you
know mild spoilers i guess
uh so you know that just know that going
in i kind of feel like
uh unfriended dark web they went in a
more
stalker direction in the sense of
uh you know this being a real like a
computer hacker that was like stalking
them
whereas the first movie went in a more
supernatural direction
and in a way even though the stalker
situation is probably more
realistic i kind of felt like the
supernatural
angle was better and creepier because
you could i mean i saw um another
reviewer say this too
is that you know in some ways having a
supernatural aspect to this
cyber stalker essentially it kind of
papers over a lot of things because if
you're willing to suspend your disbelief
and say okay well this is a ghost or
vengeful spirit doing this
then you don't get into the nitpicky
[ __ ] of like oh well a real life hacker
can't do that or a computer can't do
that or something like that because it's
like it's a ghost they can do anything
it's supernatural
so in that way i kind of feel like you
know maybe having it be supernatural is
like
the better way to go so i think that's
probably why people responded like way
better to the first one that it did the
second one
so this movie as i said came out in 2014
i think it premiered at
uh fantasia and it actually did so well
there like
you know very very positive like
audience feedback
that it got picked up by universal
pictures now i think this movie only
cost a million dollars to make they did
spend a lot um
doing kind of a lot of online uh
advertising and stuff
but it actually ended up making uh 65
million dollars back
so quite quite a good investment for you
know somewhere probably not
not as much as like something like
paranormal activity but you know along
those same kind of lines where they made
it for
not much money and ended up like making
a lot of it back which like i said was
why they ended up making a sequel to it
so what we have
is we have these like a group of high
school students
now a year prior to the events of the
movie
a student named laura barnes uh
committed suicide
now she did that after i guess her and a
bunch of
uh her friends all of whom are
participating in the skype call that uh
you know
comprises the entire movie they were all
at a party
she got really drunk and fell asleep or
passed out
and [ __ ] herself and uh one of her
friends you don't know who
until later recorded it and it ended up
going online going viral and uh the girl
laura really couldn't ever live it down
or she just went through like
you know bullying because of the video
because everybody had seen it
and uh so she ended up committing
suicide so
at the beginning of the movie it's the
year anniversary
of the suicide even though the friends
don't really uh realize this
uh at this point now we start out with
two characters blair and mitch and their
boyfriend and girlfriend
and they're kind of starting out just on
a skype call like by themselves you know
kind of like doing
little like shown or boobs and all this
other kind of stuff you know like you
know high school teenagers would do or
whatever
and then at some point um all their
other friends uh
come on to the call uh their names are
jess ken
and adam now pretty much
in within the first few minutes of the
film when all of them
come onto the skype call and are just
talking about [ __ ] that like teenagers
normally talk about
they notice that there is an anonymous
person
in the skype call with them i will say
too that i think one of the best things
about this movie
is that even though obviously it's you
know they made it on a computer and it's
like edited together to look like
you know and it's so it looks like it
happens in real time and it's like
you know everything is real like all the
skype stuff looks real all the facebook
stuff looks real
all of the everything like every window
they open
that you know they made it all look real
even though obviously they had to
finagle it like to
get what they needed to get but i think
that really adds to it because it really
it seems completely and utterly
realistic this really seems like a bunch
of teenagers
and they're on a skype call and they
have like all these other tabs and
windows open and stuff like that
and someone is [ __ ] with them over
the
internet and they can't figure out who
it is so this anonymous user turns up in
skype with the little
blue box with a little white silhouette
and this person
comes across like their screen name is
just billy227
now this user seems to be
at first you're not really sure like at
first they think it's just somebody
that's like [ __ ] with them
and when this user starts talking to
them about
laura and about laura's suicide and sort
of holding them accountable
for what happened to her for like all
the bullying that she endured
after the video came out so at first
they're kind of thinking maybe this is a
relative of laura's or maybe somebody
hacked into her facebook account or
maybe some and you know
and knows things about us and is like
using [ __ ] uh you know against us
but as the movie goes on it becomes
clear
that this is actually uh
the vengeful spirit of laura herself and
she has basically taken control of all
their [ __ ]
and can also reach out and do
other things as in she can always she
can almost try
she can almost like possess them into
doing things to themselves
so it's almost kind of so i really
really liked that aspect of it because
there really was
this kind of sense of danger where
because it was supernatural because it
was a vengeful spirit and she could
essentially
do anything uh including up to and
including like uh
possessing somebody and making them do
horrible painful things to themselves
so it really gave that its sense of
threat and it also explained
why because i think when people first
saw the trailer for this movie they were
just kind of like oh you know somebody's
stalking over the internet like just
turned the computer off like problem
solved
but uh yeah but and and i do like that
at some point like in the movie like the
characters do say hey why don't we just
like let's kick them out of the skype
call or why don't we unfriend
you know unfriend laura barnes on there
and she can't send us messages anymore
do that so they do actually try to do
all those things
but because this is a ghost or like a
spirit or something she can actually
maneuver things so that you can't do it
and she
since she can reach out from beyond the
grave i guess
and make people do things to themselves
if they don't
do what she wants them to do then
you can't log on i mean she says many
times during
the film like she's threatening them you
know you can't leave
if you log off i'm one of you is going
to die and all this other kind of stuff
and so like as it goes on she also uses
a bunch of information because she's a
ghost and she
so she's omnipotent she knows everything
so she knows all of this information and
all these dirty little secrets
that each of the uh each of the friends
has
and can use them to like turn everyone
against each other
so at some point she's like revealing
this kind of secret she's revealing that
and then so it's not
only just her being threatening it's
also
all of the friends turning on one
another because they're finding out
some of their friends like to stab them
in the back like you know what i mean
you find out that blair had slept with
this other guy like she had cheated on
her boyfriend and like you find out like
who
who was the one who uh originally took
the video who was the one who released
the video of laura barnes
and there's like other things going on
behind the scenes too
so it's almost kind of like they try to
work together to figure out at first
like who
this intruder is into their skype call
once they figure out that this is
probably a supernatural
then they almost like start to sort of
cooperate but also kind of like turn on
each other and you know
get into these big huge arguments and
stuff because they're finding out all
these horrible things about what their
friends have done behind their backs
and all this other kind of stuff so i
really really liked that aspect of it as
well
also there's some really good there's
some pretty good deaths in this too
which you wouldn't think and i really
like it's kind of effective the way
you know they'll have something like you
know like how on a real skype call like
sometimes it like glitches out or like
you know the
picture freezes or the audio's out of
sync and stuff like that
so they do that not so much that it's
annoying but
enough that it's like realistic if
anybody has to use skype and
you'll uh recognize uh what that's like
but they also use that pretty
effectively
for some of the kind of jump scare type
of things or like some of the deaths
because
as i said since the ghost can
essentially like come out of the screen
like possess
a person to kill themselves or hurt
themselves
so you have sometimes you have these
really great sequences where
one of the friends will you know their
screenal log
will like freeze up or you know they'll
hang up and they don't know where they
are
and then like suddenly it'll come on and
it'll be like this horrifying
image like you know one of the kids like
sticking sticking his arm in a blender
and things like that
but you only you don't see it um like
it's really well done but you only see
it for like a couple of minutes so there
were a couple of seconds so it's like i
think that's
really good because it leaves a lot of
it to your imagination like because
sometimes you can just hear something or
sometimes you just see it for like a
couple seconds you're like oh man that's
[ __ ] up
and it's like really [ __ ] up imagery
but it doesn't linger on it so it's like
it's
in a way it kind of makes it creepier
because it's like i said it leaves it to
your imagination
so yeah this was like just it's just
funny because as i said i'm not a fan
of found footage films i'm not and when
i say oh it's like a bunch of teenagers
talking over a skype call for 80 minutes
you know that sounds
gimmicky and it sounds lame and indeed
that's how i thought it sounded too
and that's why i never bothered watching
it because i did actually hear about
because it was kind of a little bit of a
buzz about it when it came back
out back in 2014 but
you know like i said i probably would
never have watched it if i hadn't seen a
bunch of other
horror channels and like reviewers and
stuff talking about oh give it a chance
because it's actually like way better
than you would think like it's better
than its premise sounds like
and uh i actually would absolutely agree
with that i think this was a very
it was just like a really tight like i
said it's pretty short i think it's only
like 83 minutes and it doesn't [ __ ]
around there's not like a lot of
extraneous crap it seems like very very
well paced
you would think that just watching
someone's laptop
you know and them just kind of scrolling
through the tabs and it's like you know
searching
you know searching google for things or
you know just talk
doing facebook messages and stuff you'd
think that maybe that would be boring or
it would be like
you know watching like sitting behind
your friend and like watching them fart
around the web or something but it's
it's really like oddly compelling
i'm not really sure how i mean because i
was watching
mark carmode was talking about this and
i really like him and he actually
kind of said the same thing he was like
this is like a really
way more effective movie than it has any
right being um and he's like i'm not
really sure how it would play for
maybe like way older audiences but
for you know people that grew up with
the internet that grew up with this all
all this type of [ __ ] um you know
younger audiences probably relate to it
maybe a lot more than
and i'm kind of talking like more old
old kind of people would probably just
not know what's going on i mean i didn't
i found it really really i was never
bored i was never
and i really liked too that they used
actually the um
the sort of setting of this girl because
it's all kind of from blair's uh because
she's kind of the main character i guess
if you want to say that
but it's all like blair's laptop so it's
like there's a lot of stuff of
you know just the tabs that she has like
you know the stuff that she says or
starts to say when she's like typing
facebook messages and stuff like that
and so a lot of that stuff it really it
really like informs a lot of the
character without them having to say
anything
outright you know anything outright so i
think that's really cool how they kind
of used
this format to give you information
because there's so much stuff going on
uh you know in the other tabs that she
has
you know on her thing and like sometimes
you can see some little things on her
desktop and stuff like that
so it's like it really gives you an idea
of the character without
them having to do a lot of exposition
and stuff which i thought was actually
really clever
but yeah so if you don't like found
footage movies or you
this sounds like the worst thing ever
then
maybe maybe you wouldn't like it but i'm
just saying that if it sounds like
if the premise sounds interesting to you
i think that this is definitely one
that is maybe like a little bit
underrated
and i'm not going to say i don't want to
recommend it to everybody because some
people might just think it was annoying
or whatever
but it's like i found this like way way
better than i was expecting and i think
a lot of other people did as well
so let me know if you've seen it it's on
netflix like i said
i've heard the sequel is not good but i
can't
really say because i haven't seen it
i've heard the buzz like the sequel
wasn't that great and like i said the
sequel
went more in a realistic stalker
direction more
rather than the supernatural direction
of the first one which i think was
probably a mistake but whatever
um but yeah it's on netflix so check it
out and
let me know what you thought of it if
you loved it if you hated it or if
you've already seen it
and again did you think it was better
than you thought it was gonna be do you
think was worse than you thought it was
gonna be or whatever
just uh let me know down in the comments
and that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys on
the next one
bye